bonjour bloedow bonjour philo mais on a
écouté tout à l'heure ce témoignage de
cette personnalité ukrainienne
professeur d'université qui est dans sa
ville on a diffusé tout à l'air
également ces images du président
volodymyr zelensky c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on a commencé pour le dîner lenski
auquel les américains auraient proposé
de l'évacuer il aurait refusé
absolument il résiste et résiste il est
là il se montre il communique tous
azimuts là par exemple effectivement
récemment les américains lui ont proposé
l'évacuation et il leur a dit je cite le
combat est ici j'ai besoin de munitions
pas d'un taxi nous allons défendre
chèrement notre cren d'envoyer il est
encore à kiev il refuse d'être évacués
l'ambassade de france aussi avait dit
que le cas échéant ils pouvaient se
réfugier à l'ambassade de france
puisqu'il est des forces spéciales
françaises sur place mais lui refuse
parce que en gros s'il évacués s'ils
quittent kiev après tout ce qu'il dit ou
il dit à ses compatriotes de se battre
de résister évidemment c'est fini quoi
donc il est obligé de rester à kiev ce
un pari dangereux mais c'est un pari
courageux sachant que les russes ne
l'ont pas caché ce qu'ils veulent c'est
décapité ce pouvoir à kiev et à
commencer bien entendu par ce président
ce qu on peut aussi noter boulot c'est
que l'opération était lancée jeudi matin
et à l'heure qu'il est peut-être que les
ukrainiens résiste un peu plus que ce
qu'avaient prévu les russes oui très
certainement parce que d'abord l'armée
ukrainienne quand même a été fortement
renforcée depuis 2000 14 depuis
l'annexion de la crimée où là les
ukrainiens n'avaient rien pu faire face
à l'offensive qui était bien plus
localisées de vladimir poutine avec
l'épisode vers vous souvenez qui
officiellement n'étaient pas des soldats
russes donc depuis l'ukraine a vu le
danger des occidentaux si donc les
finances sont arrivés l'armement les
équipements et d'ailleurs le président
zelensky dit que ça que ça continue
arriver que les armes continuent à
arriver donc
l'armée craignant les monteurs puissance
mais évidemment elle n'est pas encore à
la hauteur de l'armée russe et il y a
aussi les civils ukrainien 900000
réservistes qui ont été rappelés tout
d'abord ce qui serait d'ailleurs parfois
des des problèmes aux frontières quand
les familles quittent l'ukraine parce
que les hommes de façon les hommes ne
peuvent pas par là les hommes de 18 à 60
ans ne peuvent à cause de cet appel
lancé par céline ce qu'ils ne peuvent
plus quitter l'ukraine via tous ces
civils aussi vous savez on a vu des
reportages ils apprenaient où il
reprenait le maniement des armes on leur
apprend à faire des cocktails molotov on
sent qu'il va y avoir de la part du
peuple ukrainien une grande résistance
et que pour vladimir poutine et l'armée
russe ce ne sera pas aussi simple on
sait aussi d'ailleurs maintenant qu
apparemment au sein de l'état-major
russe certains généraux franchement
n'était pas chaud pour aller frapper un
pays qui est considéré comme un pays
frère